[Music]  hi I'm Dylan and I'm Jacqueline Dylan's  mom and we recommend succession it's the  only show i'veseen I'm Chuck I don't  watch TV  I'm not TV watcher we watched like three  hours one time watch three hours I felt  like I was back in college it's great  it's a peek into the ultra-wealthy they  just have a lot more at stake seemingly  to them because of the money  it'll be very serious and all this stuff  is going on and then they drop jokes in  it that are super morbid as well like  ruining someone's life  cheating making fun of being poor season  finale was we were snow going to my  husband's ball game by going what are  y'all doing it's the season finale if  you haven't ever seen succession I  recommend that you get somebody that you  really want to snuggle up with and watch  it because it's very captivating and I  love to snuggle  [Music]